hallo und farbig worden eine frage an
dich hast du noch kontakt zu irgendeinem
aus der bewerber zeit wenn ja zu sehen
nein habe ich nicht denn ich war drinnen
und ich muss ehrlich sagen chemie so ein
bisschen als ich drin war aber da so was
weiß man auch wirklich erst wenn man
wirklich drin war
denn das recht da teilweise eine sauerei
im haus aber ist auch egal
ich habe keinen kontakt zu den leuten
man hat immer im haus gesagt wir werden
so in kontakt bleiben
aber ich wollte eigentlich nur weg von
der ganzen szene von der ganzen alles
was damit zu tun hat wollte ich einfach
nicht mehr beiden haben so auch die
bewohner denn wie ich auch schon im
interview gesagt habe ich bin natürlich
kommen auch alleine klar mit freunde
oder ohne klick zu harten einsatz
so ist das bei mir und deswegen habe ich
mit niemandem auch da irgendwie nichts
zu tun